well I'm joined now by the former
Chancellor quasiquatic quasi great to
see you
you've never said sorry I've never what
happened a year just over a year ago
what I've said I bear responsibility for
it why not say something and what I want
to do is to make sure that we actually
get back uh to a growth agenda because
it's their responsibility for well I
think the way that we delivered it and
the and the speed with which it was
delivered was wrong and I put my I've
put up my hand uh frequently and said we
should have taken more time we should
have had a more balanced approach uh and
I've said that repeatedly in interviews
uh on television what I'm really I'm
really curious why you've never been
able to bring yourself to say the simple
words I'm sorry after all the damage
that was inflicted by that ruinous
44-day regime of Liz truss and I'm sure
that you would say and we'll come to
this a lot of it was on her but I'm not
here to apportion blame I mean that's
the that's one of the reasons
that wasn't the reasons why I get it if
you take responsibility why you also not
prepared to say sorry so I think there's
a it sounds like a loyally distinction
but I think there's a difference between
saying I was responsible sounds like a
bit like a kid
because actually a lot of the debate and
you've probably been following this if
you look at things like slavery and
reparations and all of that all of that
is all about saying I'm sorry and in in
those instances the people themselves
weren't entirely responsible I agree
that happens two or three hundred years
I agree with you so so what I don't see
why people today should be apologizing
for the behavior no I get that of
ancestors 300 years ago so but you were
you were the guy no but again as in
government uh there are lots of
different people there are lots of
different agencies lots of different
people who are involved so it doesn't
make any sense it doesn't make any sense
for someone like for example Jillian
Keegan to say sorry when there's all of
this stuff happened uh over over many
decades and there were lots of things
let's talk about the mini budget yeah
there were lots of things that were
going on you say it crashed pound the
the the
um Federal Reserve had put up interest
rates and the Japanese Yen and the Euro
were at 50 years the main reason as you
know the main reason the pound tanked as
rapidly as it did for a week for a week
but the main reason
because you had these billions and
billions of unfunded taxes and where and
where
straw to break the Campbell's back was
actually the guilts it wasn't the County
Market it was actually the what we call
the ldi's long-term guilt Market where
interest rates went up and there was
there was a run on that and the bank
intervened my own view I mean I didn't
sack myself I wanted to stick it out no
no and see it through
um the Prime Minister took a different
route and but do you accept that what
you did was a massive mistake so I think
that the delivery of it
um was was a mistake left a lot to be
designed over 45 billion of tax cuts
that haven't been funded even to even to
a sort of
non-academic Financial brain like mine
so look like lunacy no but the the it
was a store that bring the camel's back
so she campaigned very clearly not to
increase or a corporation tax during the
leadership and to reverse the ni
increases and that was 35 million and
what where we went too far was probably
in trying to get rid of the 45p rate so
the point about the reason I think
principally it went wrong was that there
was just too much in it because there
was immediate harm
to millions of people and there was in
the country it was a very tough it was a
very turbulent yeah your turbulence yeah
definitely yeah your turbulence was
another person's more except and I've
also openly said that you know I was
exposed uh ironically enough uh to that
as well I mean lots of people so here's
my question for you again I I'm really
I'm not going to come here and say uh
wear a hair shirt and apologize and why
not and say something why not because I
want to look forward and I want to I'm
sure you do but I want to look back for
a year old I don't think that's because
the reason I want to look back is Rishi
sunak was in competition with this trust
to be the prime minister at the time and
he warned when she was talking about all
these tax cuts she was going to do he
warned this
so I don't think the responsible thing
to do right now is launch into some
unfunded spree of borrowing and more
debt that will just make inflation worse
it will make the problem longer let's be
clear we have inflation because of our
monetary policy that we haven't been
tough enough on the monetary Supply
that's the way I would address that
issue okay but it is wrong interest
rates up mortgage is Nightmare it is it
is Liz we have to be honest we have to
be honest but borrowing your way out of
inflation isn't a plan it's a fairy tale
well he was right I think he was right
to an extent he was right completely no
no because I think where she was right
where we were right was identifying
growth and that will be an issue that
you will have endless conversations with
politicians in the next few years
because it's very unclear if you have a
very high tax system which we're
currently in how you get growth I think
where we went wrong and I'm very happy
to confess this is there was just too
much uh too quickly I think if she'd
done the measures she campaigned on I
think we'd have been okay and of course
you've got to remember that this is on
top of the energy Intervention which was
cost billions no listen there were lots
of other things yeah yeah so and I'm not
disputing that I just I find it
interesting that politicians today find
it increasingly difficult to just say
sorry so when the when the consequences
of their decisions and actions you were
Chancellor she was the Prime Minister
when the direct consequences were felt
immediately by millions of people so I
think as I said
opposed
you know reasonable person but
politicians were always being no one's
going to do that you've got to be you've
got to be you gotta apologize for this
you've got to apologize for that were
you the shortest living Chancellor in
history well actually Ian McLeod was but
that's a difference so you're the second
shortest hang on okay shortest living
chance from history she was one of the
shortest the shortest Prime the shortest
prime minister 44 days that's right
Mayhem right she couldn't even Outlast a
lettuce so on every metric of political
life putting aside everything else the
pair of you will go down in history
whether you like it or not as disasters
in that period right and I simply asked
give them the magnitude so I'm not
coming here to to formally apologize why
not sorry I am what I am saying
all right and there were lots
of course I'm curious why not and as you
why not there are lots and lots there
were lots and lots of other facts I know
but it was actually happened to believe
because that what we were trying to do
from a strategic point I know trying to
lower taxes and trying to make the
country more productive and wealth
creating and was a good thing I know
what you both believed but it turned out
you were both wrong
the implementation was was wrong I
accept that I think the Strate the
strategy was the right thing but again I
understand you don't want to apologize
my question is why because I I don't
think that the strategy was the wrong
strategy I don't apologize for the
strategy I just think the implementation
and the way in which it was delivered
could have been improved massively and I
and I've probably you said it I've
really accepted you said it was a big
mistake no I said so there were two
things there's a strategic goal I want
to have a lower tax Britain and there's
a way you get there now the way that we
the implementation we used I think left
a lot to be desired I think it was the
wrong thing at the wrong time we went
too far yes however the strategy where
we wanted to get to was absolutely
absolutely but you know that's an
important thing that's an important it's
fine but the reality of your actions is
it millions of people in this country
suffered immediate financial harm and to
those I don't want an apology from you
to me but there are people watching this
so hang on there are people watching
this who went through genuine Financial
harm as a consequence of your actions so
don't apologize to me but for them I'm
really curious why you would be prepared
to look down the barrel of the camera on
a show like this and not just say I'm
sorry so what I would do is just say you
know we could have done things better
awesome
I'm not going to apologize
for the fact I think it was the right
strategy but the implementation was
wrong
[Music]
apologize for the shocking so look I'm
not going to come here you always do
this you get people on and you want them
to sort of wear the hair shirt and no I
don't and humiliate them but I'm not I
don't have no wish to humiliate you
whatsoever I honestly don't I have zero
wifty humility I actually thought you
were going to be a really good
Chancellor but what is worth well no
thank you that's right kind of you and I
think the pair of you lost your minds I
think we went too far too far right I
accept I think you lost your minds and
you got way ahead of your sales but the
consequences of your actions led to you
being fired yeah this trust hoping that
would save her skin it didn't she then
had to go to humiliation for the pair of
you and for the country on the global
stage but again I come back to one thing
you may not want to apologize and I'm
not after it for me look look but I'm
not trying to humiliate you no no you
guys with respect quasi you guys
humiliated yourself well okay right yeah
but in the process you also expose the
country to humiliation it was a very
damaging period for Britain that in
terms of our standing around the world
and more importantly to me millions of
British people already suffering from a
pandemic already suffering a cost of
living crisis already suffering
suffering from energy costs uh going
through the roof all these things they
then had the added financial burden as a
consequence
so my point is it was a very so my point
is you're a smart guy you know that the
decisions that you took led to that
Financial harm for millions of people in
this country why are you not prepared it
always reminds me of and you're going to
laugh but it reminds me of frost trying
to get that apology out of Nixon for the
damage he'd done to the reputation of
America why don't you just take a leaf
out of nix's book he didn't want to
apologize either he resisted for years
and then eventually he sat back and you
can see his brain weren't thinking
actually you know what yes I'm sorry why
is it so hard look it's not hard is it
possible you're literally finding here
but look there were other there were
lots of other people involved in this
okay there was I'm not you were the
chancellor I'm not going to take sole
responsibility uh when there were lots
of responsibility no I didn't I have
taken responsibility you don't think you
don't think what happened it raises the
bars all I've said is that I'm I took
responsibility and and we should have
done things more measured in a
deliberate way that would have been have
you heard the Elton John song Sorry it
seems to be there yeah it's a good it's
a it's a you like that it's a very good
song you play it a lot uh I'm not a big
fan of Elton John but I like that you
know that song yeah yeah I do I do know
that song do those words resonate no all
look I'm not coming here to relitigate
you spent 10 minutes not wanting to
apologize
I've said millions of times that you
won't I bear responsibility that we
should have we did things uh in the
wrong way but in terms of the strategy I
still believe in the strategy so I don't
see why I should apologize for this
because the implementation was a total
the implementation was was so wouldn't
you implement something as a chance of
this country that causes huge financial
harm immediately to millions of British
people the the traditional thing is to
say you know what I'm sorry for the
dance and if you look at where we are
now obviously you know interest rates
have more than doubled since I'm only
talking about the consequences of your
actions since I was there I think a lot
of them I'm talking about by your own I
think thanks to quasi I'm talking about
by your own admission the consequences
of your actions as Chancellor and the
immediate impact
I'm not going to come onto the show you
were the one you were the one I wasn't
the so we've gone through this in
millions you were the chance I was not
the sole agent of what happened okay
everyone's got to apologize
that's important and I just think that
it's very easy to get politicians who
are uh ultimately responsible for things
to try and say okay I'm sorry when
politicians screw up badly and it
impacts on millions of people's lives I
think that it is not only to take
responsibility but to upload so I've
taken responsibility I accept that the
implementation being oh sorry I still
think the strategy was the right you're
not sorry for the implementation and I
think we'll come we're not sorry for the
implementation and I think we'll come
around to do they'll find it a bit
ridiculous no I don't because like
because look we're playing a game here
we're not playing games
it's not a game to the people whose
lives I was saying that I was uh
completely responsible and not
completely responsible I was involved in
those decisions uh some of those
decisions we should have been there are
people watching this now because
honestly I promise you I've interviewed
many people over the years thousands
there will be people watching this now
going why doesn't he just say sorry
what's the matter with him yeah I can
understand that but all I want to say is
that I don't apologize for the strategy
for the strategy I think it's the right
thing as we got to have you are alone
perfectly entitled I think we've got to
have a lower tax fine more productive
yes you can't well created you can't
have a lower taxation without funding it
properly yeah I agree with that and that
was what you didn't Thunder if we talked
if we'd actually talked through it if
we'd had timer that was why in the
Autumn statement I said look I'm going
I'm going to have a statement where
we're going to show spending restraint
which will fund the the tax cuts
unfortunately and it wasn't a choice of
mine I was obviously sacked because of
the turbulence because of the market
reaction I was sacked before I was able
to do that and when Jeremy hunted did
list trust say sorry to you no she
hasn't apologized to me no uh so she
screwed you basically stuck a political
knife in your back well I was sacked and
I think the idea was that she was never
apologize no no she hasn't done that and
I haven't uh insisted upon it she
and so once I was sacked
um then you know she took responsibility
we got a new Chancellor in who's still
there and a lot of the stuff do you ever
apologize for anything yeah I mean I
apologize in my private life the whole
time what was the last time that I
apologized I think um I think I picked
up my daughter from Nursery uh too late
and I apologize then a couple of weeks
so just to be clear hang on just
just you're happy to apologize to people
at a nursery school yeah it would be a
few minutes late to pick up your
daughter but you're not prepared to
apologize to millions of people so look
for screwing their personal finance so
that's you see my that's where I look at
it I know where you're coming and you
think I'm trying to humiliate you I'm
not and I'm just thinking from a public
in terms of public affairs and public
life I think politicians make decisions
um and they on the basis of evidence on
the basis of their own uh philosophy if
you like and I've never been one for
saying you know if as a politician
um you know you're personally
um damaging people there's policy
there's debates well no because there
were lots of other things I did not
personally damage those people you've
admitted the implementation and there
was a lot of questions so bad there was
a lot of context as well and you said
well forget about the context well no
you the context is important I know the
context I saw the reaction to your
policy and I think that yeah and there
was a white there was a there were lots
of things going on there was also the
time where
um I came back from Washington and was
sacked and you know I haven't asked for
apology for that that's the way uh
public affairs uh these days is
conducted and and you know people have
sincere beliefs and they want to do the
best for their country final question
they shouldn't apologize for that well
actually I think I mean you and I have a
different view maybe but but I think
you'll find it's my view is the common
view okay I honestly do and honestly I
did not get you here I actually thought
you know over time after a year you go
actually yes I'm sorry essentially as
simple as that okay and then you put up
with one day's headlines the Quasi quad
saying I'm sorry that we got it wrong
and I've damaged people's lives so I
think you said what you've got it's a
15-minute attempt and they might need to
the reason in your eyes wrestle some
kind of fake apology in my eyes get an
apology for the people whose lives
you're affected is that I think the
strategy and I think in the long term we
have to have a lower tax
for what the goal was yeah that's what I
believe you're perfectly entitled
honestly I mean this you're entitled to
believe that your philosophy and your
strategy would have worked over time but
I'm also entitled to go back to you yeah
implementation was I Reckless it was
wrong it tanked the markets it spooked
everybody in the world of of economics
and the consequence of that was you got
fired very quickly and the Prime
Minister lasted 44 days and the whole
thing brought shame on this country but
more importantly millions of people in
this country suffered personal financial
loss as a consequence of what you guys
did and I just find it baffling honestly
and I'm not trying to humiliate no I get
that because I actually I've always
liked you as a person and I did think
you were going to be a good Chancellor
and I'm sorry it didn't work out for you
but I'm actually sorry for the people
who lost money and I think they'll be
watching this going why doesn't he just
say sorry okay
last chance look I just think last
chance it was a difficult time last time
but I still believe I still believe the
strategy was there but you know the
implementation was a fiesta and and the
implementation could have been better
yeah sorry for that which I also think
we should have happened are you sorry
for that we should have had more for
more time there you go I'm sorry for the
implementation the strategy I'm sorry
and you're sorry for the damage the
implementation so so there you go you
know we've had this discussion I think
you're right to say uh on consideration
I think you're right to say people
should put their hand up and also having
put their hand up they should be able to
show some Contrition and and I'm happy
I'm sorry I'm happy to show that what
I'm not happy to say and what I stick to
is the fact that as far as this country
is concerned and it's wealth and its
prospects we cannot tax ourselves to
Prosperity but like that's a different
argument and you're perfect I made that
argument am I right in thinking you now
for the damage the implementation caused
to millions of people you're sorry I I I
show abject uh Contrition I'm very are
you sorry look look I whatever formula
of words I'm just asking are you sorry
I'm sorry
um turbulence that was causing sorry for
the damage it caused to British people
if if that's what you want me to no it's
what I want you you don't want to say
look what I want to say is that I think
the strategy was right I'm sorry for the
implementation are you sorry for the
damage caused I'm sorry for the
implementation and it was it was too far
and for the damage caused to the British
I don't know why you look they were
logically suffered financially lots of
people no but you were the chancellor
okay I was the chance to check it are
you sorry for the financial damage it
caused to the British I'm sorry for the
uh damage and uh the loss and uh and it
was a scary time and I'm sorry for that
quasi we got there okay and I've I've
not tried to drag that out of you no no
I've not tried to humiliate we've had a
good conversation yes and I think you've
come to it I've thought about what you
were saying yes and I thought actually
you know we've got to put your hand up
I've accepted responsibility a long time
ago and you've said well why don't you
get to do the step forward uh take a
step further and apologize and I've said
you know that's fair enough and now you
have yeah do you feel better now
um not particularly I don't feel better
or worse I feel I'm glad I'm glad you
have well I'm glad that you you you're
happy but I'm not happy I'm just glad
that you have not only recognized
accountability so I've totally and
responsibility but you can also
apologize now to the people who said
I've totally reckoned I think that is
the right and a year a year on we've had
an interesting debate and I'm looking at
you know splitting hairs between
responsibility and allergies and all
rest of it and I think I think broadly
you know people were adversely affected
it is a scary time particularly with
mortgages which are still going up in
many instances and I think on your on
your principle I think politicians
should put their hands up and say
they're sorry thank you quasi quality
good to see